there is a
scintillating story going around this is
this is what we've been waiting for the
Jeffrey Epstein files are going to be
unsealed we're going to find out all
this new juicy
information some of us told you at the
end of last year this was just a week
ago that we weren't going to get any
really new
information no Michael we are and next
day they say we are we're getting we're
going to find out about prince
Andrew oh the guy that we already know
about the guy that we've known about for
years he actually lost his job working
for his
mom because we know so much about his
relationship with Epstein oh okay we're
gonna find out about Bill Clinton do you
know this is one of the juicy tidbits
Bill Clinton likes young
women stop the presses okay well now we
got new stuff Epstein documents allege
sex tapes of Bill Clinton Prince Andrew
and Richard
Branson
this woman the accuser uh Sarah Ransom
claims that her friend was approached by
special agents sent directly by Hillary
Clinton who ruffled her up after she
went to police with her accusations M
Ransom later said she made up the tape's
existence okay now I don't know maybe
it's true maybe Hillary send some goons
after this lady uh maybe not I tend to
think if Hillary sends goons after you
you don't generally Live to Tell the
tale but maybe who maybe and uh so then
she goes to the cops and she says I I
have all these tapes in my possession
now are there secret sex tapes of at
least some Epstein clients maybe
including Bill Clinton Prince Ander and
Richard Branson yeah I I bet so I don't
know about those guys in particular but
certainly Jeffrey Epstein
videotaped his very wealthy influential
powerful
clients doing weird sex stuff with
underage girls
guaranteed the tapes
exist but is it these tapes does This
Woman This Epstein accuser who obviously
got kind of messed up as a young
gal uh does she have those tapes I kind
of doubt it I kind of doubt it because
in 2019 this is what two two years after
she made these accusations this woman
told the New Yorker that the tapes were
made
up she said that she made this up to
raise Intrigue into Epstein's Affairs
and to convince Jeffrey Epstein that she
had evidence that would come out if he
harmed me so this is just according to
her in 2019 what do you believe do you
believe her in 2017 and then they
intimidated her and she recanted because
she didn't want them to kill her or do
you believe that the whole reason she
said that she had these tapes was to
create a kind of dead man switch and
give herself some apparent leverage uh
so that they wouldn't kill her and then
when she she's talking to the police it
is difficult to lie to the police and
the story fell apart and she said okay I
didn't it that didn't really
happen I someone who believes that there
are sex tapes of all these weirdos on
Epstein Island I who have believed the
Jeffrey Epstein story long before many
mainstream voices believed in
it I don't think these these tapes are
real I think it's the latter I think she
was a scared confused woman who had a
kind of traumatic upbringing
and she made it up and then she admitted
she made it
up I think that's true for a lot of this
testimony all of this testimony the
unsealed Epstein
documents it's all just testimony isn't
that convenient it's all just stuff that
could be false it's all some of which
has the accusers have admitted was false
now to me it's just so convenient the
only people we're hearing about really
are the ones that we already knew about
and all of the stories that we're
hearing titillating scintillating that
they may
be can easily be denied because they're
not findings of a court they're not the
conclusions of an
investigation they're just what some
lady
said Witnesses who may or may not be
credible I just think the whole thing is
a limited hangout I think it's all fake
and silly to get us all chattering oo
whoo it's I think we finally got to the
bottom of the Epstein thing no we didn't
no we didn't the bottom of the Epstein
thing is who was he working for in whose
service did he cultivate these
relationships operate the weird sex
mansions and islands and film the
tapes who if anyone was he
blackmailing and more importantly in
whose service was he doing the
blackmailing that's what this is about
and no none of the Epstein news of the
last two weeks has gotten us one inch
closer to finding out that information
very very convenient there's a new
morning consult poll out that says that
uh faith in democracy remains very
strong uh I think this poll is total BS
so you you look at it and you can see
all the little tabs and and not only
does morning consult believe that faith
and Democracy in America remains strong
it's faith and democracy everywhere that
they take the polls all of the countries
that they survey okay uh all well and
good except that as the Harvard law
professor Adrien vermule points
out democracy means two things in
America two things that are contrary to
one another when the libs talk about
democracy in the same breath they will
talk about how important it is to kick
Donald Trump off the ballot and stop
people from being allowed to vote for
him we conservatives listen to that we
say what are you you're saying it's
Democratic to stop the people from
voting for their favorite candidate yeah
and the Liberals really believe believe
that that is democratic they believe
that democracy and liberalism are
synonymous even though
liberalism is a minority ideology it's
uh can be deeply deeply unpopular and
then it's imposed from above and it uh
is a totalitarian ideology I guess you
would say it infiltrates every aspect of
life that's how it's managed to corrode
not just federalism not just
constitutional protections but it's
corroded even the family it it's
corroded even local Rule and and it just
it's like an acid that you pour on
society until everything is just
uh divided up and alienated into the
atomic individual that's no good that's
not how I refer to democracy when I say
I support democracy what I mean is I
support the people voting for who whom
they want to vote
for that's a very different meaning of
democracy so I just don't think this
this pull means anything at all it be
it's similar to saying Hey do you
support Freedom you could ask me a
rather conservative person do you
support freedom I said of course I
support Freedom you could ask some crazy
purple hair doing a bunch of drugs who's
in you know a lesbian thruple with with
three dudes in a billy goat and I would
say do you support freedom and she would
say of course I support freedom but we
would think that the other one does not
support freedom because we have
different understandings of Freedom the
lib would believe that freedom is the
ability to do whatever you want
particularly following your base
passions and I would believe the
opposite I would say the true freedom is
disciplining your base passions and
following your rational will and
bringing that into Accord with the
Divine will that that true freedom is
the right to do what we ought not the
ability to do what we wish at our lowest
levels those are totally in Conflict but
a morning consult survey that said do
you all support Freedom say 100% of
people support Freedom 100% of people
support democracy and and the centrists
are going to sit back here and say okay
good the guard rails hold no big deal
the guard rails are not holding right
now this is Happy Talk this is papering
over a fundamental difference and it
gets down to a number one National
bestselling book that I recommend that
everyone read called speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
thank you
because all this happy talk is papering
over a a battle over language who
definition of democracy is going to
Prevail for all of human history
democracy was the political order that
the people want the Liberals have
totally perverted that meeting they will
go on TV with a straight face they will
say we've got
to legally prohibit Donald Trump from
appearing on a ballot in order to save
democracy we've got to overturn the
Trump Administration after he wins in
2016 to save democracy oh no the
hungarians are electing Victor Orban
he's a threat to democracy Georgia
Malone is a threat to democracy the
brexit's a threat to democracy all these
things that the people keep voting for
it's a threat to democracy who's going
to who's going to win that battle over
the word it's a very very powerful word
still has so much currency but but for
all intents and purposes it no longer
means what what it traditionally has
meant what it actually means have you
yet subscribed on YouTube to this
channel you haven't what that's crazy do
it you have to do it that way you'll get
more of this cool content
man ring the bell see you next time